سيدي ماذا تقول للأمريكيين
القلقين بشأن حقيقة أن
الرئيس ترامب لم يتنازل بعد
وماذا قد يعني ذلك
للبلد حسنًا ، أعتقد أنه أمر
محرج
بصراحة تامة الشيء الوحيد الذي
كيف يمكنني أن أقول هذا بلباقة  أعتقد أن ذلك
لن يساعد في إرث الرئيس
وأعتقد أنه أه أعلم من
مناقشاتي مع القادة الأجانب حتى
الآن
أنهم يأملون أن
يُنظر إلى المؤسسات الديمقراطية للولايات المتحدة مرة
أخرى
على أنها قوية ودائمة واه
ولكن أعتقد في النهاية  من اليوم أه
تعلم
أن كل شيء سيؤتي ثماره في
20 كانون الثاني (يناير)
وبين الحين والآخر آمل أن يكون
التوقع هو
أن الأمريكيين
يعرفون ويفهمون بالفعل أنه كان هناك
انتقال
حتى بين الجمهوريين
الذين صوتوا  بالنسبة للرئيس ،
أتفهم الإحساس
بالخسارة ، لكني أعتقد
أن غالبية الأشخاص الذين صوتوا
لصالح الرئيس
صوتوا له كثيرًا ولكن  صوّت الكثيرون
لصالحه وأعتقد أنهم يفهمون أنه يتعين علينا
أن نتحد معًا وأعتقد أنهم مستعدون
للوحدة وأعتقد أنه يمكننا إخراج
البلاد
من هذه
السياسة المريرة التي رأيناها خلال
السنوات الخمس الماضية والسبع سنوات الماضية ،
شكرًا  أنت السيد الرئيس المنتخب خلال
الحملة الانتخابية ،
لقد قلت إنك لم تكن ساذجًا بشأن مدى
صعوبة
توحيد البلاد ، فقد مرت ثلاثة أيام الآن
بعد
أن تم تعيينك
كرئيس منتخب ،
يقول الرئيس نفسه إنه فاز في هذه
الانتخابات كما فعلت إدارته.  لم
يتحرك إلى الأمام لمنحك الوصول إلى ما
تحتاج إلى القيام به لبدء عمل الانتقال الخاص بك
قبل بضع دقائق فقط ،
عندما سئل وزير الخارجية عما إذا كان
سيتعاون مع انتقال سلس ،
قال إنه سيكون هناك انتقال سلس
إلى ثانية
إدارة ترامب ، أتساءل عما إذا كان
لديك رسالة
إلى الرئيس الذي ربما
يراقب الآن وكيف تتوقع أن تكون
قادرًا على العمل مع الجمهوريين في حين
أن الكثير منهم رفض حتى الآن
حتى  اعلم بنصرك
جيداً أولاً وقبل كل شيء أه بدأنا بالفعل
في الانتقال نحن على قدم وساق
واه القدرة
أه لأه الإدارة بأي شكل من الأشكال
بعدم إدراك هذا ضد
فوزنا أه لا أه
يغير الديناميكية إطلاقاً فيما  نحن
قادرون على القيام بذلك ،
لقد أعلنا بالأمس كما تعلمون
المجموعة الصحية التي
قمنا بتجميعها اليوم ،
سنمضي قدمًا
بطريقة
متسقة مع إدارتنا
للبيت الأبيض
ومراجعة من نحن ذاهبون  لاختيار
أطباء مجلس الوزراء
ولن يوقف ذلك أي شيء
وأه ولذا أنا واثق من أن أه حقيقة
أنهم ليسوا على استعداد للاعتراف
بأننا نريد في هذه المرحلة
هو أه ليس له تأثير كبير في
تخطيطنا وما نحن  إعادة قادرة على القيام به
من الآن
وحتى 20 يناير